welcome back to special report let's
take a look at what's happening on the
ground in ukraine we've seen incremental
movements from the russian forces a
little bit of movement around kharkiv
more of a movement from
the north and east towards kiev but a
lot of bombardment in different places
over the past 24 hours especially down
here in maripola that's where that
hospital was hit
the movement that we've seen
has kind of
met the expectations but not really
encirclement of keeve there you see key
but these forces are getting closer and
trying it seems like setting up
an area to try to cut the capital city
off but they're doing it basically with
bombardment and a lot of civilian
structures as you look at the bridges
we've been talking about the nuclear
facilities all throughout the country
they are a real concern and up here in
chernobyl we'll talk about it a little
bit later electricity was cut off
they're saying the radiation levels are
fine
but obviously the iaea very very
concerned about all of these different
reactors and nuclear facilities now as
you look in the south we mentioned
maripole and this
was a significant hit over the past
24 to 36 hours
really taking a strike as russian forces
obviously are controlling the the city
of curson and expected to come towards
odessa we have not seen anything from
the sea uh towards odessa but when you
talk about mariopol
the bombardment has been significant
take a look at this this is a mall
in mario poll this is june 21st these
two facilities you can see the cars out
front of the mall well this is
the after
march 9. you can see the devastation
here on this mall and this other
facility and this other building
and we're seeing that in a number of
buildings inside mario paul including
that maternity hospital
and the horrible images that we saw from
there mentioning chernobyl and the
concerns we continue to bring these
stories of people in ukraine whose lives
are being upended by this war hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else